portion and then a group portion you'll
be assigned groups in advance and
there'll be numbers on the chairs for
the room that you're in so you'll know
where to go sit and the way that will
work is you'll first you the individual
part you'll turn that in and then you'll
receive another exam for the group part
and go in discuss your answers agree on
them and then scratch that off to see if
you got it right and then when you're
done you'll hand that in as your group
one and question splitting into the two
routes again love us later yes great
question asks is whether or not related
terms
yes we're again gonna do that and that
will your assignment I think it's likely
to be the same as last time but I will
confirm that we might have make it
slightly different because some SCPD
students will be joining us for this one
that didn't before and vice versa so
it's possible particularly if we were
right on the borderline wheel you'll be
in different rooms this time so we'll
announce that just as a reminder right
now we're basically done with all of the
assignments so this is a great chance to
be focusing on the projects you should
have been getting feedback about all of
those along with with a little bit of
information back about your project and
the person who graded it will have
signed that so that's a great TA to go
ask questions I've been there office
hours or on Piazza but you're welcome to
go to any of the office hours to ask
about project questions and that poster
session will be at the time the original
time announced which is suboptimal but
what can you do and we're gonna be in a
morning on the last day of finals so
that was the one that we were assigned
you may also have any other questions
about this who here went to Chelsea's
talk on Monday okay for those of you
didn't get to see it tell C's talk will
be online it's a really nice talk about
meta reinforcement learning it will be
covered on the quiz next week but pretty
light because you haven't had much
exposure to that idea so again just as a
recap for the quiz the quiz will cover
everything in the course but things that
you didn't have a chance to actually
think about because you didn't get
practice on it with an assignment we
will test more lightly it also will be
multiple choice I highly recommend that
you take the quiz from last year
ignoring any topics that we haven't
covered and do that without looking at
the answers
one of the robust findings for
educational research is that forced
recall is incredibly effective at
helping people learn forced recall is a
nice way for testing so this is of
course in the case where you're not
gonna be assessed by it so you just can
use that to check whether or not you
understand these things and look at
anything we look up anything they might
you might have questions about any other
questions alright so let's go ahead and
get started um we're gonna talk today
about battery enforcement learning and
in particular safe bat reinforcement
learning I'll define that what that is
this is a topic that I think is
extremely important we do a lot of work
on it in my own lab and most of the
topics I'm gonna focus on today will be
work that came out of work that was done
by my postdoc Phil Thomas who's an our
professor UMass Amherst but the work he
did before he worked with me and some of
our joint work and I'll also highlight
some other related work so let's think
about a simple case and let's think
about doing a scientific experiment
where you have a group of people who are
we're gonna call the a group and they
get to first do this particular type of
fractions problem this is a fractions
problem for one of our tutoring systems
where people are having to add fractions
together and then reduce the sum to the
lowest terms and then they have to do
something where they do cross
multiplication and then after that they
can examine and the an average score of
a 95 and then we have the B group that
does the same activities but in the
opposite order and then they get an
average score of 92 and the question is
for a new student what should we do and
what would I what would what additional
information might you want to know in
order to be able to answer this question
so feel free to shout that out so what
would you need to do for like I now a
new student comes along let's imagine
our objective is to get a high score on
this exam for that student to get a high
score on this exam so what which
sequence of activities would you give to
that new student in order to maximize
their probability that they get a good
score on this exam
indicating hopefully that they've
learned them
yeah do you know how big in New York so
one great question is to say how big is
the scoop so how large is an A and you
might want to know this for a number of
reasons for example if the number of
people in Group A is one and the number
of people in Group B is two maybe these
are just sort of statistical noise
between these distinctions what else
might you want to know yes so suggested
you might want to know the variance
what's another thing you might want to
know this is just a mean so what is the
variance what other pieces of
information might you want to know so
other certain forms of statistics about
sort of you know the distribution I'm
thinking about something also more in a
different direction
yeah the people in the group suicide
better group or high school maybe the
maybe group a is kindergartners and
maybe Group B is you know high schoolers
and we're all regressing enough so yeah
so who's in these groups and in addition
to that often you'd want to know who is
the new student so is the new student
and a kindergartener our high schooler
okay so there's really a lot of
additional information that you'd want
to know in order to be able to answer
this question precisely and it involves
a lot of different challenges and one of
the challenges here is that if group B
is different than group a then we have
this fundamental issue of censored data
that you don't get to know what would
have happened in Group A if they had had
the same C or in the group B if they'd
had the same sequence of interventions
as in Group A so this is sort of the
fundamental challenge that you'll never
know what it would be like if you're at
Harvard right now
that there's this you only get to
observe the outcome for the action
that's taken we've seen that a lot of
reinforcement learning and that's true
in this case to where we have old data
about sequences of decision so it
requires this counterfactual reasoning
another thing that it involves is
generalization so here is a simple
example where you can think of it
basically as being just two actions each
of the two different problem each of the
two different problems and you can think
of this is the reward the delayed reward
maybe of a reward of zero reward of zero
and then a reward at the test score and
so here there's only two actions and who
knows how big the state space is it
depends how we'd want to model students
but we don't want to think about
combinatorially all the different orders
of actions and even if we're writing
down a decision policy that might start
to be very large very quickly and so
we're gonna need to be able to do some
form of generalization either across
states or actions or both so that we
don't have to run combinatorial number
of experiments to figure out what's most
effective for student learning so we're
gonna talk about this problem today in
the context of batch reinforcement
learning which we can also think of as
being off line so this has to be off
line batch all right and this is
frequently gonna generally be off policy
now we've seen a lot of off policy
learning before you learning is an off
policy algorithm but I want to
distinguish here that what we're gonna
be mostly focusing on today is the case
where someone has already collected the
data so we already have a prior set of
data and then we're going to want to use
it to make better decisions going
forward now this problem comes up not
just in the case that I just mentioned
but in a huge number of different
domains you could argue that areas like
become economics and statistics of
Epidemiology are constantly asking these
sort of questions it comes up and things
like maintenance you know what sort of
order of actions do you want to do to
make sure that your machines your cars
run for longest it comes up in
healthcare like what sort of sequence of
activities should we give to patients in
order to maximize their outcomes their
quality adjusted life years and in many
of these cases it's going to be state
dependent because what's gonna work best
for patient a is gonna be different than
what works best for patient B now one of
the big challenges here too is that when
we think about a lot of the cases where
we have this old data it's going to be
high-stakes scenarios which means that
whether it's because we have really
expensive you know nuclear power
equipment which we don't want to go
wrong or we're treating people for you
know really significant disease
is then we want to make sure that we
make good decisions in the future so we
might may or may not have a lot of data
but the data that we have is precious
and we want to make as good decisions as
possible from that so that means we need
to have some form of confidence in how
well it's going to work going forward so
we would really like to have some sort
of upper and lower bounds on its
performance before we deploy it and in
general we just want good methods to try
to estimate if we do this counterfactual
reasoning if we think about how well
people are you know how much more
healthy people might be if we were to
treat them in a different way
how confident can we be before we
convince a doctor to go actually deploy
this so what I'm going to talk about
today is thinking about sort of this
general question of how can we do batch
safe reinforcement learning safety
concern a lot of different things when
I'm talking about safety today I'm
mostly going to be thinking about this
in terms of this competence this ability
to say before we deploy something how
good do we know it is now there's
different forms of safety there's things
like safe exploration making sure you
don't make mistakes online there's risk
sensitivity thinking about the fact that
each of us is only going to experience
one outcome not the expectation so we
may want to think about the full
distribution instead of averaging but
what we're going to talk about today is
mostly still thinking about expected
outcomes but thinking about being
confident in the expected outcomes and
so in general we would like to really be
able to say with high confidence this
new decision policy we're gonna deploy
for patients or for nuclear power plants
or for other sorts of high stakes
scenarios we think it's better we think
it is better than what we're currently
doing and why might you want this you
might want to serve to a guarantee kind
of monotonic improvement particularly
these high stakes domains which is
something that we've seen earlier this
quarter okay so let's talk just briefly
about some of the notation some of this
will be familiar I just want to make
sure that we're all on board with that
and then I'll talk about through some of
the different steps we might think about
to try to create batch safe we enforce
my learning algorithms
so where's usually going to use PI to
denote a policy we're going to use T or
H to denote a trajectory I'll often use
Big D to denote the data that we have
access to you this is like electronic
medical record systems or you know data
about power plants etc and for most of
this word assumed that we know what the
behavior policy is so we know what was
the mapping of States to actions or it
could have been histories to actions
that was used to gather the data can
everybody give me an example where that
might not be reasonable where we might
not know the behavior policy in many
many cases where the data is generous
we will not know what PI P is so when we
look at medical help data we typically
don't know what PI B is so you know if
this is generated by doctors we
typically don't know what PI B will be
there's obviously guidance but we don't
typically have access to the exact
policy people used and and if we did
they probably wouldn't have phrased it
as like you know a stochastic process
that's like when someone comes into
their office with probability 0.5
they're gonna treat them with this
versus point 5 they probably think of it
in deterministic terms and they probably
wouldn't think of it in terms of these
if-then rules so there are many cases
where we don't have that we've done some
work on that recently other people have
as well I might talk about that briefly
at the end but for most of today we're
gonna assume that we have access to this
so this comes more you may example where
it is reasonable to assume that we have
PI P
like a diagnosis that's based on this
very say like South Island or something
yeah so in some cases you know through
surveys like sometimes you have like an
algorithm to make a decision or if you
know a clear set of guidelines are you
gonna see if something similar or
different so if you have a power plant
with maintenance records and we can
establish maintenance plan those records
match the plan that you basically had
pipe yeah so when those are cases where
you have these fixed protocols another
example I often think about is you know
when your decisions were made by
reinforced Polonia agents or or they're
made by supervised learning agents and
if you go to a lot of different like how
you know Google serves ads we know
exactly how it serves ads it has to all
be logged and there's there's an
algorithm that is making that decision
so in many cases we have access to the
code that is being used to generate
algorithms automatic generated ASIJ ins
automatically and in that case we can
just look it up long as we've saved it
so and our objective as usual is to
think about how do we get good good
policies out and good policies with good
values when we think about trying to do
safe patch reinforcement learning in
this setting we're gonna be thinking
about how do we take that old data so
we're gonna sort of take our data as
input and push it through some black box
and get out a policy that we think is
good so we're gonna have sort of some
algorithm or transformation that is
instead of interacting with the real
world and getting to make decisions and
choose its data it's gonna just take in
this fixed data and output a policy and
one thing that we would like is that if
we feed data into our algorithm and our
algorithm could be stochastic then the
value of the policy it outputs so you
can think a of D so that's you know this
is being our algorithm a let's get out
put some policy that might be a
deterministic function that might be a
stochastic function whatever policy it
outputs we want it to be good ideally at
least as good as their behavior policy
so that's what this first equation says
is it says the value of whatever policy
is output by our algorithm when we feed
in some data set we would like it to be
as good as what the behavior policy that
Jen
that data set whatever that value was so
this is sort of the value of the policy
used to generate the data now we don't
normally we're not normally given via PI
B directly but can anybody give me an
example of how we might learn that given
a data set which was generated on policy
from that policy generated using that
policy yeah I think saying is that you
know you could use that data I don't
know if you could do dynamic programming
because you don't necessary have access
to the transition in reward models but
you could do something like Monte Carlo
estimation you could average the reward
I'm let's assume in the data set that
you get to see states actions and
rewards so you can certainly just
average it you know averaged over all
the trajectories so we can get an
estimate we can estimate P PI B by
looking at let's imagine it's an epoch
episodic problem so you can look at some
overall I equals one to number of
trajectories of the return for that
trajectory this is the return which is
essentially just doing Monte Carlo
estimation because you know that that
data was generated on policy so you can
just average so that'll give us a way to
estimate V PI B but then we need some
way to estimate V of our algorithm
outputting D and that means we're gonna
have to do something off policy because
in general we're gonna be wanting to
find policies that are better than PI B
which means that they would have had to
be making some different decisions and
I'll just highlight here that you know
sometimes you might not just want to be
better than the existing behavior policy
but you might need to be substantially
better often if we're thinking about
real production systems it costs time
and money and effort whenever we want to
change protocols if you want to get
doctors to change the way they're making
decisions you want to change things in a
power plant there's often overhead so
often you might not just need to be
better than the existing sort of state
of the art you need to be significantly
better so the same types of
ideas we're talking about for relative
to sort of the current performance you
can always add a Delta so that so good
they have to be at least this much
better and so again just to sort of
summarize what does this equation says
it says I want to have situations where
the policy that's output when I plug in
my data set I want that to be better
than my existing policy with high
probability so Delta here you know it's
going to be something between 0 and 1 so
now let's talk about how we might do
this
I'm gonna start with off policy policy
evaluation so the idea in this case well
ok first I'll go through all three of
these really briefly and then we'll go
stuff to them more slowly so the three
things in terms of stuff we might want
to do safe patch reinforcement learning
there's tons of variance for each of
these depending on the setting we're
looking at is we need to be duped to do
this off policy batch policy evaluation
which is we need to be able to take our
old data and then use it to estimate how
good an alternative policy would do we
might want to get confident bounds over
how good that is
so this could just allow us to get some
estimate of PA of D or V PI e e''z PI e
is often used to denote an evaluation
policy a policy we want to evaluate so
the first thing is just doing off policy
policy evaluation the second thing is
saying how would we know how good that
estimate is so this is an estimate it
could be really good it could be bad so
you might want to have some uncertainty
over this estimate so that we can
quantify how good or bad it is and then
finally we might want to be able to
actually take like you know an argument
over possible policies so you might want
to be able to do something like Arg max
hi V PI e with some confidence bounds so
you in general you're not going to just
want to be able to evaluate how good
alternative policies will be you're
going to want to figure out a good
policy to deploy in the future which is
going to require us to do optimization
because we don't normally know what
good policies yet so differently we're
going to end up evaluating the number of
different policies so we can think of it
as roof the first part is we're gonna
take our historical data take a proposed
policy plug it into some algorithm that
we haven't talked about yet and get out
an estimate of the value of that policy
and we're gonna talk about how to do
important sampling with that and then
after that we're gonna go into the high
confidence policy evaluation and safe
policy improvement to get confidence
bounds we're going to look at Hopf ting
we've seen hoff ting before and i as
something that we looked at when we were
starting to talk about exploration so
when we look at high confidence I'm
gonna think back think back to
exploration so an exploration we were
often trying to quantify how uncertain
we were about the value of a policy or
its models in order to be optimistic
with respect to how good it could be and
use that to drive exploration but we
also could have computed confidence
bounds that are lower bounds on how good
things could be and that's going to be
useful here when we try to figure out
how good policies are before we deploy
them and we'll do often calling for that
and then finally we're gonna be able to
want to do things like safe policy
improvement which is can you enter the
question of saying if someone gives you
some data and they say hey can you give
me a better policy can one have an
algorithm that either gives a better
policy that it is actually better like
when you go and deploy it with high
probability or can the algorithm also
know its limitations and say nope
there's no there's no way for me to give
you a policy that's better so I think
it's also really nice to have algorithms
that are aware of their own limitations
we're doing quite a bit of work on that
in my lab right now so that when people
who are using these particularly for
human-in-the-loop systems that they can
understand if the algorithm is giving
out garbage or not and so in this case
the idea is that sometimes if you have
very little data you can't do
improvement in a confident way so for
that example I showed you before we had
like two different ways of teaching
students and someone you know made the
good point of saying how many people are
in each of these if only one person has
tried either at these and someone says
can you definitely tell me what's gonna
be better for students in the future you
say no because there's only one data
point like there's no way we would have
enough data from you know one data point
in each group to be able to confidently
see in the future how we should teach
students so I think that the safe policy
improvement needs us to be able to both
say when we can be confident about
deploying better policies in the future
or when we can't so we're gonna look at
sort of a pipeline for how to answer
that sort of question all right so let's
first go back to go and think about a
policy policy evaluation so the aim of
this is to get an off policy estimate
that is unbiased so we want to get sort
of a really you know a good estimate of
how how good an alternative decision
policy would be so we have data right
now which is sampled under some policy
that's called a behavior policy pi2 so
we have like this data set this is D
which is giving us through these samples
of these trajectories and then we want
to use them to evaluate how good an
alternative policy would be and while we
could do this with something like
q-learning
we want to do it with a different method
that's gonna allow us to get better
confidence intervals and where it's
gonna be an unbiased estimator so in
q-learning if we think back to sir what
Q learning was doing you know Q learning
is off policy we couldn't do this with Q
learning is off policy and it it samples
and it bootstraps and because it samples
in bootstraps it can be biased and so
we're gonna want to do a different thing
right now which still allows us to be
off policy but in a way that we're not
biased that our estimator might not
systematically be above or below
particularly cuz right now we're always
going to have finite data we're never
gonna be in the asymptotic regime where
we have tons and tons and tons of data
and we can sort of assume this went away
so again let's think about the return GT
is the return it's just how much forward
we got under a policy you know either
over a finite number of
it's like for one episode or across all
time and our policies just are the value
of a policy again is just the expected
discounted reward of that so the nice
thing is that if pi/2 is stochastic the
data that you're using that you're
gathering from your behavior policy then
you can use it to do off policy
evaluation this would have been
essential for doing Q learning - and one
of the nice things is that because we're
kind of following this Monte Carlo type
framework you don't need a model and you
don't need to be Markov so that's really
nice because we're gonna end up getting
an estimator that is unbiased and it
does not rely on the Markov assumption
holding and in many cases the Markov
assumption is not going to hold it
particularly when we start to think
about patient data or other cases where
we just have the set of features that
happen to have been recorded in our
dataset and who knows whether or not
that system is Markov or not we've
certainly seen in some of our projects
that it is not and that in some of those
cases if you make the assumption that
the world is Markov you're really bad
estimates of how good you know an
alternative way of teaching students
might do okay so why is this a hard
problem well it's because we have a
distribution mismatch okay so if we look
at imagine we just had a two-state
process or we thought about you know
kind of this is s and this is or like
that we can say this is the probability
of your next state s prime and I've sort
of made it smooth we could think of it a
Gaussian here and this is under PI
behavior under PI evaluation it might
look different versus this in general
the distribution of returns you're going
to get the sequence of the state action
reward next state next action next
reward so this sort of trajectory the
distribution of trajectory is going to
be different under different policies so
the distribution of tau here is not
going to look like the distribution of
tau here if it looks identical
what does that say about the value of
the two policies so what exactly so what
that is correct if I if the distribution
of states and actions that you get under
both of these policies are identical
then the value is identical and we saw
this idea also an imitation learning
when we are going to be doing sort of
state action or state feature matching
now in this case we're talking about not
just states and actions we're talking
about full distributions because our
full trajectories because we're not
making the Markov assumption but the
idea is exactly the same the only way we
define the the value is basically the
probability of a trajectory and the
value of that or you know the sum of
rewards in that trajectory so if the
distribution is identical then the value
is identical we don't care if the
policies are different because we
already know how to estimate the value
so the key problem here is that they're
going to look different which means that
you would have went done different
things under a different policy so it's
like you know right now maybe you go and
visit this part of the state space a lot
I'm skinny and this part infrequently
and now you're gonna have an alternative
policy which only goes here and
frequently and goes over there a lot but
thinking about in this way it gives us
an idea about how we could look at our
existing data over there and make it
look more like that does anybody have
any idea of how we could do that so if
someone gives you a bunch of
trajectories how might you maybe change
them so they look like the distribution
you care about yeah right so we can do
important sampling here okay so let's
just for view and refresh important
sampling so the idea is that for any
distribution we can reweighed them to
get an unbiased sample okay so let's
imagine that we have data generated from
where we want data generated from some
distribution queue we want to estimate f
of X okay so we'd have want to get f of
X under the probability distribution Q
of X so we can multiply and divide by
the same thing
it's incorporated another distribution
it's just a different distribution over
x times Q of X f of X DX okay so we can
just rewrite this as being equal to
integral over X probability of x times
this quantity which is Q of X divided by
P of X times f of X and let's imagine
that we actually have data from P of X
so we want data from Q of X but we have
data from P of X so we can approximate
this by 1 over N sum over I Q of X I
divided by P of X I f of X I where X I
is sampled from P of X I wrote when I
first learned about this number of years
ago and I thought it was a really lovely
insight just to say we're just gonna
reweighed our data and so we're gonna
focus on the data points that come from
you know that are ones that we would
sample under the distribution we care
about we're just going to re-weigh them
so they look like they're having the
same probability that they would under
under Q of X in our case add our desired
policy okay so the important something
works for any distribution mismatch if
you have data from one distribution you
wish you had it from another and this
can come up and things like physics
often you have really rare events like
Higgs bosons and in those cases you
might there are different scenarios
where you could relay the estimation of
the true expectation okay this is for
just generic distributions let's remind
ourselves how this works for for the
reinforcement learning setting so again
we're gonna have our episodes we can
call them H we can call them tau which
is a sequence of states actions and
rewards and then if we want to do
important sampling or let me just write
this out so in this case we're gonna
want to get something like p of HJ under
our desired policy so what does they get
that going to be that's going to be our
probability of our initial state so
assume that's identical no matter what
policy that you're in
and then we're gonna have the
probability of taking a particular
action given we're in that state times
the probability that we go to a next
state and the probability of the reward
we saw and we can sum that over J equals
1 up to n minus 1 or LJ minus 1 so we
just repeatedly look at what was the
probability where you pick the action
the transition model and the reward
model so that's how what we have for the
probability of a history and then if we
want to do this for important sembly and
so what we want is we want to have the
probability of this history we need to
be able to compute this ratio of Q of X
divided by P of X which for us is going
to be the probability of a history J
under the evaluation policy divided by
the probability of a history J under the
pave your policy so and we want to do
this and we're hoping that everything is
going to cancel because we don't have
access to the dynamics model or the
reward model so unfortunately just like
what we saw in some of the policy
gradient work it will so if we have
probability of HJ divided by PI B we're
going to have again the initial state
distribution which will be the same in
both cases and then we have this ratio
of probabilities of probability of AJ
divided by s J this is under PI e
probability of AJ divided to give an SJ
for pi B and then the transition model
and reward model
okay and so this is nice because this
cancels and this cancels because the
dynamics of the world is what determines
the next state and the dynamics of the
world is what determines the reward and
notice here just to make this not
incredibly long here I've made a Markov
assumption so this is the Markov version
but it you could do you could condition
on the full history so this trick does
not require us does not require the
system to be Markov because no matter
whether your your dynamics depend on the
full history or the immediate last step
they're gonna be the same in the
behavior policy and in the dynamics and
in the evaluation policies you can
cancel these and same for the reward
bottle so this this insight does not
require a Markovian assumption and what
that means is that we just end up
getting this ratio of the way we would
pick actions under the evaluation policy
divided by the ratio of the way we would
pick actions under the behavior policy
here we are assuming that same
trajectory is generated by two different
policies yes we're assuming the same
trajectory was earned by two different
policies yes sir we're saying for this
trajectory what's the probability you
would have seen this under the behavior
policy versus the evaluation policy and
so if it was more likely under the
evaluation policy we want to up wait
whatever world we got for that
trajectory and if it's less likely under
that evaluation policy you want to
download it so the intuition is that we
have a bunch of trajectories and their
sum of rewards so we kind of have these
eight you know H 1 comma G 1 pairs so we
have these sort of trajectory sum of
rewards and if we had the same behavior
policies evaluation policy in order to
know how good that evaluation policies
we've just averaged all of those G's but
they're different and so what we want to
do is we want to say four H's that are
more likely under evaluation policy up
wait those four H's
are less likely under your valuation
policy down weighed those so that you
get a true expectation when you do those
G evaluations
G waiting's so that makes sense we might
have any questions about that part so
this is just super telling us how weary
weight our data it's allowing us to get
a distribution that looks more like the
distribution of trajectories we would
get under our evaluation policy by the
final final row we have denominator
policy we get that estimated parently
good question you know where does the
behavior policy come from basically like
that like what is these probabilities is
that the question so I think it depends
so in the case if you're if it's a
machine learning algorithm used to
generate your data you just know it like
you would just look up and your
algorithm and see what the probability
distribution is and for today we're
gonna assume that this is known and it's
perfect that is obviously not true when
we get into people data in those cases
there's a couple different things you
can do one is that you can build
estimators that are robust to this being
wrong so you can use other ways to try
to kind of be doubly robust if that
estimator is wrong in others you can
take the empirical distribution and
actually there's some cool work recently
I think it was from Peter stone slab at
UT Austin showing that sometimes you
it's better to use the empirical
estimate than even if you know the true
estimate like in terms of the resulting
estimator which is kind of cool
okay so this is just writing that out in
logic instead of we hand writing it and
so this just writes out the the
probability of a history and now we can
see that equation that I put here so you
know the value of the policy that you
want to evaluate is going to be this
ratio of histories times the return of
that history and what we said here is
and this is no 1 over N is that this is
simply the probability of taking each of
those actions I'll write it just in
terms of the PI notation so this is pi
e of a J given SJ I I equals 1 to the
length of your trajectory divided by PI
B of AJ I all times the return of that
particular history so the beautiful
thing is you can this is an unbiased
estimator this really does give you a
good estimate of the value under a few
assumptions which I'll ask you guys
about in a second and I'm you don't need
to know the dynamics so no dynamics no
reward no need to be Markov can
everybody um tell me a case where maybe
this doesn't work starting from your
initial policy to your final policies
they couldn't be that different right
because otherwise then you the samples
in previous records wouldn't be useful
exactly so what does me about is you
know how different can PI e and PI be
allow us to this ok that was exactly
what I was about to ask you guys about
so can I read give me what they think
might be a condition for this estimator
to be valid like we're might be some
cases where you would expect this might
do badly in terms of differences between
the evaluation policy and the behavior
policy
and that has to do with the probability
of taking actions in a certain state
I mean if either his probabilities are
too small you're gonna have things blow
up in bad ways yeah so when we say this
either these probably are just small
this might be bad which of these ways is
worse right so if PI B is really small
or you know zero this could be really
bad now PI B can't ever be zero and us
observed something so that's good
because we're getting data from PI B and
so we would never observe a trajectory
under which PI B is zero but it could be
really really small so it could be you
know you see something and it's
incredibly unlikely there but your
behavior policy would have generated
that and what if it is zero so it might
be zero for some actions what would that
do if it's zero in places where PI a is
not zero so what happens if PI B of a
some particular a is equal to zero but
PI e of a governs zero this you know
greater than zero might be one what
might be bad there like you think this
is a little raise hands for a second if
that happened do you think we raise your
hands either yes if you think this is a
good estimator or no if you think all
bets are off so if the behavior policy
is zero probability of taking an action
but the evaluation policy has a positive
probability to take an action raise your
hand if you think things estimator could
be really bad that's right yeah so you
know if there are cases where you're
just never trying actions like you never
saw actions in your data that your new
evaluation policy would take you can't
use this so we often call this as
coverage so coverage or support so we
often make a few basic assumptions in
order for this to be valid so our
coverage or support normally means that
PI B of a given s has to be greater than
0 for all a and s such that PI e of a
given s is greater than 0 so you kind of
have to have support over it doesn't
have to be nonzero everywhere but for
anything you might want to evaluate for
anyway
if you're really going to generate data
from your evaluation policy and it might
take an action you need to be able to
get to that state and you mean to be
able to take that action with some
nonzero probability high B is the same
as PI to in the upper part right that's
right okay
originally I thought you'd said that the
evaluation policy was the one that you
observed the data from that's thanks for
making me clear play that um the the
behavior policy is always the one you
observe data from evaluations the way
you want to look at and apologize
notation often here is a little bit
snuggly because I think people sometimes
call the evaluation policy the target
policy or evaluation policy or you know
one or two and most of the time the
policy is to gather the data is called
the behavior policy yeah question is
whether or not what if they're both zero
is that a problem would you ever get
data from that right yeah so if they're
both sir it's okay so you don't actually
have to this is does not require you to
take to have a nonzero probability of
taking every action in every state so it
can be okay so PI B of a given s can
equal zero if PI e of a given s is equal
to zero it's fine for that to be the
case you just can't have any case where
you would never have either reached the
state or generated that action for
things that you could have potentially
done under your evaluation policy and
that doesn't sound too strict but in
practice that can be a big deal so if
you think about like Montezuma's Revenge
excuse me or different forms of atari
like under a random make up your policy
you're never gonna get to see a lot of
states and you're never gonna take
actions in those states like you're just
it's incredibly unlikely unless you have
an enormous amount of data so in
practice you can think of sort of the
behavior policy you have is kind of
defining like like a ball under which
you can evaluate other potential
policies so if you have like it's not
actually a sphere but like you know if
it's um if you have a behavior policy
here you can think of kind of having
some dis
since metric under which you can still
get good estimates app ie so you kind of
have a radius and it depends on these
are sort of essentially the the policies
for which you have support over and
anything else you can't evaluate all
right so just to summarize there you
know important sampling is this
beautiful idea that works for lots of
statistics including for reinforcement
learning I think the way the first
introduction to this I think it was
first used for I think in join a pre
cups paper 2000 around then it's been
around for a lot longer but I think we
reinforcement learning that was the
first introduction of using this of
course these ideas also come up in
policy gradients type type methods and
the great thing is that is this unbiased
and consistent estimator just a
refresher consistent means that
asymptotically it really will give you
the right estimate so know as n goes to
infinity be our estimated to be PI e
goes to PI you just kind of a nice
sanity check as you get more and more
data um you will get the right estimator
and just to check here it this is you
know under under a few assumptions you
have to have support all right now in
our particular case I we can leverage a
few aspects of the fact that this is a
temporal process so again like what we
saw for policy gradient type work call
policy gradient methods we can leverage
the fact that the future can't effect
past rewards so when we think about
generating these importance ratios we
only have to for a particular time step
T instead of multiplying it by so I
guess just to back up for there remember
that GT is defined to be equal to you
know the rewards like the sum of rewards
so when we think about this equation for
an important sampling let me just go
back to here so this could be expanded
into you know r1 plus gamma times r2 +
gamma squared times r3 and right now in
that equation that's like multiplying
your full product of importance ratios
times each of the rewards so we're not
doing any it's the same ratio of
probability of action given by
probability of action multiplied by each
of these different reward terms but
since you know r3 can't be affected by
any actions that are 4 or longer in some
ways you're just this isn't wrong it's
just that you're introducing additional
variance so similar to what we saw in
policy gradient stuff we don't actually
we only have to multiply by that product
of ratios up to the time point at which
we got that reward so this allows us to
get to per decision important sampling
so this is only up to only up to point
away because if the future can't
influence past rewards and again this is
independent of it being Markov or not so
this is just the fact that it's a
temporal process and we can't go back in
time alright so another thing just in
general is that an important sampling
we're just sort of these weights of
these weights are these products you
know products of like picking an action
under different policies so we often
call these weight terms nicely and
confusingly with all the weights we
talked about with function approximation
and weighted important sampling compared
to important sampling just renormalizing
by the sum of weights the reason you
might want to do this is that as we were
talking about before if you're PI B is
really tiny so let's say this this might
be super tiny super small for some
trajectories then that can mean that
your importance weight for those
trajectories is enormous in fact we have
a proof that you know the generally the
size of your importance weights can grow
exponentially with the horizon
and so these importance weights can be
incredibly large in some cases and so
what weight and importance Emily does is
it just read normalizes so effectively
you're making it so while your
importance weights there's somewhere
between zero and one and then you're
using that when you're reweighed your
distribution so when you do this this is
something that's very common to do again
this predate the reinforcement learning
inside but has also been used in
reinforcement learning this is this is
biased and still consistent so that
means asymptotically it's gonna get to
the right thing and lower variance so
we're essentially gonna play the
bias-variance tradeoff that we've often
seen looking at cue learning versus
Monte Carlo estimates Monte Carlo were
unbiased but very high variance true
learning bootstrap so it's biased but
often much better because there's so
much lower variance we did an important
sampling as much lower variance
empirically much much better most of the
time particularly for small amounts of
data yep comment on before we were
saying that we were intentionally
designing something to be unbiased so
we're going to ignore certain techniques
and now we're reintroducing bias and I
guess what is the intuition behind when
it's okay I guess to introduce bias and
like when and why okay so you just made
a big deal before about saying let's go
for unbiased estimators and now you're
telling us that we're gonna go back to
bias and then in that case you know how
do we make decisions about when this is
okay I think it totally depends on the
domain I and it also I think one
challenge and issue that comes up is if
things are unbiased it's often easier to
have confidence intervals around them we
know better how to do that and when it's
biased it's often hard to quantify
I think I'll talk briefly a little bit
later about times where we really just
want to directly optimize for bias plus
variance like we want to look at
accuracy means greater the summit bias
and variance and so then I think you can
it provides you a way to directly
trade-off between those two because
you're like if I know I want to minimize
mean squared error that's the sum of
these two that gives me a way like a
principled way how to trade those off I
think another thing I often like just
first of a sanity check is that if it's
biased but still consistent
that's sort of a nice sanity check it's
like okay maybe there's a small amount
of bias early on but eventually if I get
a lot of data it's really giving me the
right answer in some of the function
approximation stuff we saw for
q-learning that's not true
we just all bets are off who knows
what's happening asymptotically but
again it depends on that it depends on
the data it's a great question it's a
big challenge in the area okay so as I
was just saying in this case you know
weighted important sampling it's
strongly consistent you're going to
converge if you have a finite horizon or
one behavior policy or bounded rewards
and fill and I said that if you look at
Thomas and Brent scale we think about
this for the RL case in our ICML 2016
paper it's one reference for this okay
so we're gonna have these estimates they
may be if we're using weighted important
sampling and there might be a little bit
biased but lower variance otherwise
there might be high variance but low
bias or zero bias what's something else
we could do so let's briefly talk about
control variance and be thinking your
head again it back to policy gradients
and thinking about baselines so just
from a statistics perspective you know
if we have an X we have the mean of that
variable if it's unbiased it means that
our estimate of the mean is matching the
true expectation and then we have our
variance so let's imagine that we just
kind of shift these estimates okay so
we're gonna just gonna subtract a random
variable Y and in your head you can
think about this as like a cue function
like that so you know why might be a cue
function and expected value of y might
be a V if you think about cubing SN a an
expected value of Y being an average
over all the actions you could take in
that state so then if you redefined your
Muzo X is going to be like let's we're
gonna be going back towards trying to
get our estimate of B PI e then if you
subtract off something else and add on
this expectation you still get an
unbiased estimator so we can just write
that out
here so X minus y plus expected value y
just equal to expected value of x that's
expected value y plus expected value of
y you can do this you can do this in
statistics you can subtract a variable
and add on its expectation and average
that does not change the mean of your
original X but you might ask why would I
do that
so you can do this for anything like any
these are where x and y are random
variables so these are general just any
random variables where Y is called a
control variant and this may be useful
if it allows you to reduce variance and
that means that you know Y has to have
something to do with X okay if you just
subtract off something random this is
probably not gonna be helpful but if you
subtract off something that allows you
to have some insight on X in our case
we're gonna mean 10 things that allows
us to help predict the value then we
might get a lower variance so we can
look at this by looking at what is the
variance of this weird quantity mu hat
where we have this X minus y plus the
expected value of y we can write it down
as follows X minus y plus expected value
of y now the variance of the expected
value of y there's no more variability
in that so we can just say that's the
variance of X minus y so what that means
is that we're gonna get something which
is variance of X variance of Y and the
covariance of the two so if it is the
case that the covariance of x and y
meaning that they you know there's
relationship between these two variables
one of them is giving us information
about the other if that is bigger than
the variance of Y then you're gonna have
a wind then you're gonna have that the
resulting estimator so if this is true
if true yep true variance the MU hat is
gonna be less than variance of X so this
is nice because it means that we didn't
change the mean and we reduce the
variance which in some ways kind of
seems like a free lunch but it's not
really a free lunch because we're using
information that is actually telling us
something about X this is very similar
to us using a baseline
and policy gradient we're instead of
just relying on the Monte Carlo returns
we could also subtract off a baseline
like the value function so you can do
this an important sampling as well so
where X is the important assembly in
estimator and y is some control berry it
typically you know this can either be a
cue function which you build from an
approximate model of viet Markov
decision process can be a cue function
from q-learning
this gives you some way to get we can
think of this as q some some estimate
state action value and doing this is
called a doubly robust estimator doubly
robust estimators again i where in
statistics for a long time and around
2011 were brought over to the delivery
were brought to the multi-armed bandit
community like the machine learning
multi-armed bandit community Dudek yeah
and and why are they called doubly
robust well the idea is that if you use
information both from like your normal
important sampling plus some control
variate like a q value estimate you can
be robust to if either of those are
wrong so either if you have a poor model
or you have a bad estimate if your
control barrier is bad so you know why
would this be important well if we go
back to sir question and some other
people's questions an alternative is
just to like do Q learning on your data
right but Q learning might be biased or
it might be a horrible estimate and who
knows if it's good but it might be good
so if it's great good you'd like to be
able to say we've got a good estimate or
if it's bad you'd like to say that it
sort of your important sampling can
compensate for that and this says that
either if you have a bad model or you
have error in your estimates of Pi B
this is like those cases where we've got
data from position so we don't really
know what the pain of your policy is so
if you have inaccuracies there then you
also would like to if it turns out your
control barrier is accurate then you can
also do well now in some cases both of
these are bad in that case kind of all
bets are still off but it gives you more
robustness about different parts of the
way you're trying to estimate how good
your evaluation policy is and Phil and I
discussed sort of different ways to do
this as well as doing it in a weighted
way so I'm incorporating weighted
importance sampling so what does this
allow you to do okay I'll briefly show
the equation then essentially the idea
here is these are like the important
sampling weights this is the raw returns
and then we can add and subtract this
was Y and this is the expected value of
y these can be computed by computing
like q-learning or doing like an
empirical model and doing dynamic
programming on it you could get these
sort of estimates of Q of Pi e and lots
of different ways and they might be good
or they might be bad but you can plug
them in and often they're gonna end up
helping you in terms of variance so
let's see empirically what this does so
this is a really small grid world think
something on the order of like you know
maybe 5 by 5 4 by 4 this is a really
small world we're using it to try to
illustrate and understand the benefits
that these different types of techniques
so what's on the x-axis this is the
amount of data so this is the size of
the data set what's on the y-axis this
is mean squared error this is the
difference between our estimate of the
evaluation policy and the true
evaluation policy and you want this to
be small so smaller better and this is a
log scale so what do we see here so one
thing you could do is you could build an
approximate model with your data that
model might be wrong like maybe you're
making a Markov assumption and it's
wrong or maybe you know there's other
parts we just can't estimate well so
this is the model based so this is just
we use a model and we compute the PI e
for that model so we take our data we
build an MDP model then we use that to
then that's like a simulator and then we
can just compute V PI E
you can see here it's flat in this case
I'd have to remember here I think we
were using a different data set either I
would have to double check whether or
not just after we have that number of
episodes the model just doesn't change
with further data like the model just
isn't great
maybe we're not using all the features
that we should be or the world isn't
really Markoff and so you kind of have
this fixed bias your model can be
asymptotically wrong the estimates you
get from it can be asymptotically wrong
if your model is not a good fit to the
environment the second thing we can do
is we can do important sampling so
important sampling is unbiased it's
going down as we get more data as we
would hope eventually it should collapse
to zero but we'd like to do better than
that so now this is per decision
important simply you can see you get a
benefit from leveraging the fact that
rewards can't be influenced by future
decisions that reduces the variance kind
of gives you this nice kind of automatic
shift out if you do W robust you get a
significant bump
so what's W robust doing again it's
combining our approximate model plus is
so you can see again here we're getting
a significant bump now I talk about this
mostly in terms of mean squared error
but I think it's really important to
think about what mean squared error
means so mean squared error here is you
know how accurate we estimating this
beep ie minus the true one but we can
alternatively think about this in terms
of how much data we need to get a good
estimate so look at this this is if you
want a mean squared or one
maybe that's sufficient maybe that's not
that means that under a per decision
importance Havoline estimator you would
need two thousand episodes and with W
robust you need less than 200 so that's
awesome because it means that we're
needing like an order of magnitude less
data in order to get good estimates and
a lot of real-world applications we just
don't have enough data you know you
might not be a lot of patience with a
particular condition and you'd really
like to still be able to make good
decisions for them and so you need
estimators that need much less data to
give you good answers so that's why this
is important
all right and then in these cases we can
see also that if you do weighted
important sampling and weighted super
decision that also ends up helping a lot
here is if you do weighted doubly robust
again sort of answering that question of
when should you do you know how do you
trade-off between this bias and variance
here we can see that if we do some form
of weighted W robust which is one of the
things we introduced our ICML paper you
again get a really big gain so we had
this two there mister there right so now
you're needing like five episodes to get
to the same so again some of these
improvements commit this is of course
grid world right like that's you need
one needs to look at this also for the
particularly germane ones interested it
but it indicates that in some of these
cases by being a little bit better in
terms of these estimators you can get
substantial gains in terms of how
accurate your estimators are alright
again to continue on the start of like
how do you balance between variants and
bias one thing that Phil and I thought
about is okay well you know you might
want to have lower bias and very and how
do you do this trade-off let's just
think about optimizing for it directly
so our magic estimator just tries to
directly directly minimize mean squared
error so so again let's say mean squared
error it's going to be you know it's a
function of bias and variance so if you
knew what bias and variance was you
could hopefully just optimize this
directly do we know what biases so bias
again just to remember is bias is the
difference between this - this lets bias
do we know that no unfortunately if we
knew that we knew the bias then we
wouldn't have to do anything else
because we would know exactly what the
real value was so a big challenge when
we're trying to do this work is how do
you get a good estimate of bias or like
an under or overestimated bias and just
briefly the idea that we had there is to
say if you can get confidence intervals
which you can use an important sampling
so let's say I have these you know this
is my s2
from important sampling and I have some
uncertainty over it so this gives me
some estimate with some upper and lower
bounds so you know I'm like you can do I
say the value is 5 plus or minus 2 and
then let's say I have a model I'm a
model that I built from this data and
then I used it to evaluate and I got
another estimate up here so I have a V
PI and this is using a model let's say
this is 8 so what is the minimum bias my
model has to have how could you use
these confidence intervals to get like a
lower bound on how how bad my mom
assumed these confidence intervals are
correct these are real confidence
interval so we know the real value has
to be between 3 & 7
what's the what's the minimum bias that
my model would have 1 right because it's
this difference so this gives you a
lower bound on the bias so how far off
you are from these confidence intervals
that gives you a lower bound on the bias
it's optimistic you're buying your model
might be way more biased but it gives
you a way to quantify what that bias is
and that's what we use in this approach
so we combine our important assembly and
estimators and think about how variable
they are we have to get an estimate of
their variance as well as the bias on
the model and that allows us to figure
out how to trade-off between these and
again you get you get a really
substantial gain often this is still
grid world but you're gonna get again
roughly an order of magnitude difference
in some domains you're gonna need an
order of magnitude less data and in this
case I've just zoomed in so you don't
even see some of these other methods
because there's so much higher up ok so
you know that's one thing that we could
do to try to get to a good off policy
policy evaluation estimates I'm I
haven't talked to you too much so far
about like how are we gonna get these
confidence bounds over those but I've
mentioned sort of a number of different
ways that we could try to get just an
estimate of you know few ie so we want
to get some estimate of this new
alternative policy that we might want to
unleash on the wild
oh I'm gonna skip this part I'll just
say briefly you know there are some
subtleties here with whether or not you
know what's the support of your behavior
policy and how we do some different
weighting and can we improve over this
sort of weighted and important sampling
the answer is yes you can do some
slightly different
waiting's and I'll defer that and then
also another really important question
really important in practice is that
your distributions are often non
stationary like you know imagine that
like you're looking at patient data and
during that time period like some new
food pyramid came out from food a Drug
Administration and so everyone changed
how they're eating um so now that you
know the dynamics of your patients are
gonna be really different than before so
you'd like to be able to identify
whether or not you have some
non-stationarity in your dataset like if
the dynamics model of the world is
changing so we have some other ideas
about how to handle that okay but now
let's go to and say let's assume we've
done this off policy policy evaluation
we've gotten out some estimate of these
how good our alternative policy would be
and we want to go beyond that and we
want to get some confidence over it so
again remember we're trying to move to a
world where we can say you know the
probability that the policy output by
our algorithm being better than our
previous policy is high say with high
probability we're gonna give you a
policy that's better which means not
only do we need to have an estimate on
how good that policy is but how much
better it is or not in your behavior
policy okay how would we do that
so let's first consider using important
sampling plus hop dings inequality again
let's think back to what we are doing
with exploration to do a high confidence
off policy policy evaluation so just as
a refresher Mountain car is this simple
control task where here you have your
agent trying to reach here we get high
reward and we're gonna have data
gathered from some behavior policy and
we want to try to learn a better policy
from it and be able to get confidence
bounds over its performance okay so
remember that in hop dings inequality
it's a way to look at how different your
Your Meme is from your average so far so
how different can be how can your how
different can your
mean B - you're true mean and it gives
them you were bound on that in terms of
the amount of data you have so it's a
function of them out of data you have
and it depends on the range of your
variables so we thought about this for
arms which might have rewards of between
0 and 1 and then B would be 1 okay so we
can use hoppings inequality also talked
about it briefly for you can use it
model-based reinforcement learning let's
think about using it in the context of
this off policy evaluation so we can
also use it using our old data to try to
estimate what the what our upper lower
bounds might be on the value of the
evaluation policy so let's imagine that
we use a hundred thousand trajectories
and the valuation policy is true
performance is point one nine and if we
use Huffington quality we are very
confident that the new policy has at
least minus five million okay and we
know the real reward is somewhere
between zero and one but Houghton's
inequality gives us this bound of minus
five million and that's true right like
you know is like point one nine is
greater than minus five million but it's
not particularly informative like we
know that the real returns for the for
this domain is somewhere between zero
and one and if we use Huff things in
equality there we're getting something
that we'd call as vacuous okay so you're
getting a bound that is true but
entirely uninformative because it is
incredibly negative right like we know
that this is the true true value is for
all policy is between okay so why did
this happen let's look at important
sampling important in sampling says
we're gonna take this product of weights
and as we talked about before this might
be pretty small so let's imagine this is
like you know 0.1 so then you have 10 to
the L like if you take a
series of actions let's say for every
single action of that trajectory it was
pretty unlikely which you often need in
domains like mountain car because in
mountain car you have to take a pretty
specific sequence of actions in order to
finally see some reward at the end and
under a policy that is not optimal it
might be pretty unlikely to see those
series of actions so let's say you know
most of your data you never get up the
hill in like one or two of your data
points you actually get up to the top of
the hill and those were very rare
trajectories which means your important
sampling weights are going to be
extremely high it's gonna be this you
know 1 divided by 0.1 up to that that's
just enormous you know so these can
start to be incredibly large and hosting
inequality depends on this the range of
the potential returns you have what are
the range of our potential returns the
range of our potential returns are G
times our product of I equals 1 to T of
our importance weights so B is equal to
max over this it says in the maximum
case what could it look like your return
is and so it's gonna depend most on what
your real range is our real G is going
to be between 0 & 1 and this product of
important sampling weights and that's
where the problem is the product of
important sampling weights can be
enormous because you have really
unlikely sequence of actions and then
you get this blow-up alright so if we
look at that here we can get this
distribution and some of the some of
these are incredibly large and that
means that our Hoff tting inequality
ended up being cuz hop ting again is you
subtract be basically minus B times
square root of 1 over n so if B let's
say let's say your trajectory lengths or
something like 200 which is pretty
similar reasonable for Monte Carlo I'm
sorry for a mountain cart then you'd
have something like 1 over 0.1 to the
200 times 1 times the square root of 1
over and roughly right and so you'd have
just this crazy crazy large term and
you're subtracting this
so that would mean that your bounds are
vacuous basically have no idea how good
this evaluation policy would be let me
have any questions about that about why
that issue occurs okay so the insight
that Phil had in some of his previous
work is just get rid of those just cut
it down so if you remove this tail what
does that do to your expected value it
just decreases it so if you ignore those
like really really crazy high returns
you're not gonna get an estimate anymore
that's as good but it's just gonna get
smaller
you're not going to overestimate it so
again if we're thinking about safe
policy improvement we're concerned about
deploying policies that are worse than
we think they are in practice what this
is gonna do is say we're gonna
underestimate how good our behavior
policy is or our evaluation policy is
and so if we underestimate it that's
okay because that's safe like if we
don't deploy things that actually would
have been good maybe there's a lost
opportunity cost but it's not going to
be bad for the world so that's what the
insight was for here is that you could
like remove this upper tail and so you
don't need to read proof but the idea is
that you can basically define a new
confidence interval this is conservative
and you can think about how you choose
that conservatism depending also the
amount of data you have so here's the
beautiful take home so let's say that
you kind of use 20% of your data to
figure out exactly how to tune this
confidence interval so this is sort of
sets your confidence interval and then
your next part to compute your lower
bound so for mountain car with the same
amount of data I've got a 100k
trajectories so this is the new
estimator and you get the the new the
estimate of V PI so this is a lower
bound on V PI e it says it's gonna be at
least point one four five and the true
value is point one night and this is
compared to all these other forms of
concentration inequalities which were
all except for Anderson really really
bad so things like turnoff tufting and
these other ones you don't have to be
familiar with all of these but basically
it just says if you use other approaches
to try to get this lower bound they
would have been entirely vacuous where's
this once
okay we're not sure exactly how good it
is it's gonna be at least poor 0.14 five
and the real value is point one nine
it's not perfect but you know if your
behavior policy was 0.05 that would be
good enough to say you should use the
new thing so they use this idea for
digital marketing this was some work
that Phil had done in collaboration with
some colleagues over at Adobe and the
nice thing about this is you can say you
know if I want to now figure out if I'm
gonna deploy something get more
effective digital marketing and I have a
access to a previous data can I say with
what confidence I can deploy something
that's gonna you know generate higher
clicks get more revenue and these
confidence bounds turn up to be tight
enough that you could actually know that
the new policy is gonna be better which
was pretty cool yeah you can also so
this is one form of trying to get those
confidence bounds turns out you can also
use t-test and empirically that's often
very good and some of you guys might
have seen some of these and some of
yours to suppress I'll just really
briefly say cuz we're almost out of time
that you can combine these ideas and
then think about trying to get these
lower bounds and combine it with
optimization so you can think about
doing this for a number of different
policies trying to compute lower bounds
on all of them then using that
information to try to decide which one
to deploy in the future in a way that is
safe okay so you can sort of say I'm
gonna use some of my data to optimize
some of my data to to try to evaluate
the resulting one and make sure that
it's got a good confidence bound before
I deploy it and again you can do this in
digital markings on the other work that
Phil Thomas and I have looked at is
using a diabetes simulator and looking
at whether or not we confer higher
performing policies for things like
insulin regulation using some other
ideas and something that in a way that
you could be with high confidence better
before you deployed I'm gonna just skip
briefly through this there's this is a
really big bottle like if this is an
increasingly big area of work in the
community I think a lot of people are
thinking about this counterfactual
reasoning issue because we have more and
more data from electronic medical record
systems that we'd like to use to improve
patient
we've data you know on online platforms
etc there's a lot of additional
challenges things like how do you deal
with long horizons the fact that
important sampling can be unfair what do
I mean by that I mean that essentially
different policies when you evaluate
them might have different amounts of
variance depending on how well they
match to your behavior policy because of
that it may be hard to decide which of
those you should deploy we have various
that were thinking about when the
behavior policy is unknown where we
combine these ideas with deeper all
networks and also thinking about
transfer learning so I know Chelsea
talked about meta learning on Monday one
of the interesting ideas here is if
you're building these forms of models
can you kind of use the same ideas of
fine tuning in the reinforcement
learning case so can you think about
building models for our policy
evaluation that leveraged its data that
does not match the policy you care about
in order to get generally better models
and things like health care I think that
can be pretty helpful but there's a lot
of additional work on this and there's a
number of other groups that are thinking
about these types of ideas and also on
campus if your interests and those ideas
in general there's also a number of
great colleagues that are thinking about
this from other perspectives people
coming it from the perspective of
economics or statistics or epidemiology
and it's been really fun to try to get
to collaborate with these people as well
so just to pop up a level briefly the
goal in these cases to think about if
you have some set of data want to go
from data to a good new policy okay and
you want it to be good in a way that you
know something about the quality of it
before you deploy it and so that's
really what sort of safe off policy
policy evaluation and selection or
optimization is about and so in terms of
the things that you should understand
from here you should be able to define
and apply important sampling know some
limitations of importance sampling lists
a couple of alternatives no you why you
might want to be able to do this sort of
safe reinforcement learning like what
sort of applications this might be
important in and sort of find what type
of guarantees we're getting in these
scenarios so that's it and then next
week we'll have the quiz on Monday and
then on Wednesday we will talk about
Monte Carlo tree search Thanks